avez vous déjà essayé la boulette de
viande ou la saucisse végétal si oui
vous n'êtes pas les seuls et encore
plusieurs consommateurs vont essayer
cette année car les protéines végétales
ne connaissent pas la crise une nouvelle
étude montre que la transition vers les
protéines alternative se généralise tant
chez les consommateurs que chez les
géants de l'agroalimentaire on jouait
d'ailleurs les investissements en
capital dans les protéines végétales
avait déjà atteint 1,1 milliard de
dollars g discuté d'ailleurs avec
sofiane belmouden qui est à londres
bonjour monsieur benmiloud oui vous êtes
chargé de relations investisseurs chez
faire alors c'est un réseau qui se
spécialise en risque en opportunités
liées à la production animale intensive
on va commencer tout d'abord par un
chiffre d'ici 2025
les investissements dans les protéines
alternatives vont atteindre 18 milliards
de dollars qu est ce qui explique leur
popularité et une forte demande de la
part des consommateurs
donc le marché des protéines alternative
a connu une croissance fulgurante ces
dernières années par exemple aux états
unis en 2019 la vente
le liquide à base de soja rebond de
liquide végétaux a connu une hausse de
200% alors que l équivalent de vente de
poules étaient en baisse de 13%
pareil pour la viande de la base à base
de plantes ou le fromage à base de
plantes et ont connu des taux de
croissance assez importante donc il ya
un réel changement dans les habitudes de
consommation et un changement qui a été
et bégadan par la crise du du co lead
qu'il y a un peu mis en exergue tous les
problèmes liés à la production de
protéines animales dans l'est dans les
fermes d'élevage intensif
oui parce que mes désillusions également
à certaines ces abattoirs là alors ç'a
un impact aussi sur les habitudes de la
consommation et que les gens craignent
davantage la viande
oui tout à fait disons que les
consommateurs se sont rendus compte
qu'il y avait un problème au niveau de
ces abattages mais également des usines
de transformation de
conditionnement de découpe de la viande
on a eu des cas même au canada avec deux
usines du groupe car lille qui ont fermé
au moins au mois d'avril à chambly et
dans l'alberta
mais également en france en allemagne
tout récemment avec l' usine tony's donc
ça si les gens veulent mieux margée
généralement également les gens veulent
mieux manger c'est vrai l'une des
raisons qui explique également
l'augmentation des ventes
c'est le taux de reggane y semer de
végétariens à nice mme qui est qui en
rose mais disons que de plus en plus de
personnes veulent tester comme vous
l'avez dit au début la société ge est
allé le burger dg talent comme
alternative crédit de la viande et
pendant la crise on a vu également des
problèmes éthiques et moraux c'est à
dire avec des cheptel de porcs de poules
qui ont dû est qu'ils ont dû être
éliminés parfois de de stockage donc ça
aussi ça eu un impact dans les dents
dans les traîne de consommation monsieur
belles mélodies chose également qu'on
attendait au départ c'est que les
boulettes de viande végétal savait pas
le même goût que la viande est ce que
l'industrie à améliorer également le
produit lors des dernières années oui
tout à fait de toute façon une des clés
du succès aujourd'hui c'est que peu
d'énormes investissements en recherche
et développement ont été ont été menées
par les producteurs de protéine
alternative pour essayer de vraiment
réplique est limité à la fois de goût
mais également la texture de la viande
donc effectivement c'est sans fin sans
cet apport niveau recherche et sans ses
efforts pour faire en sorte que la
viande d'origine végétale est plus ou
moins le même goût la même odeur la même
texture on n'aurait pas connu à mon avis
le développement fulgurant pour nous
donner un état grave
qu'est ce que ça représente donc le
marché pour les protéines végétales
versus le marché de la viande
actuellement le marché total de la
viande aujourd'hui l'échelle globale et
1,5 trillion de dollars dans 1500
milliards de dollars le marché de la
viande alternative représentent
seulement un pour cent de donc de toutes
ses ventes avec des prévisions de
croissance de 3% d'ici 2025
mais certaines études démontrent que
qu'on pourrait atteindre 40% à 60% par
don d'ici 2040
surtout lorsqu'on aura des des
technologies de plus en plus évolués
avec le développement de viande de
cellulaires etc
donc ça reste quand même un marché d'un
marché de niche mais un marché en énorme
croissance donnée au début la viande le
fromage végétale en pleine croissance
donc une recherche de la banque ubs
démontrer que c'est un marché qui
devrait peser 85 milliards de dollars
d'ici à 2030 et le conseil national de
recherches du canada l'estiment à 11
milliards d'ici 2022 donc qui est plus
ou moins en ligne avec les prévisions de
18 milliards d'ici à 2025 plus ou moins
doués techniquement forte croissance
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça d'ailleurs que
les géants de l'agroalimentaire se
tournent de plus en plus vers cette tare
c'est ce qu'on fait des actions
concrètes du côté de ce genre de
l'agroalimentaire oui tout à fait donc
il ya deux raisons qui poussent ces
géants de l'agroalimentaire à ce projet
à se tourner vers ces protéines
alternative c'est comme vous l'avez
mentionné donc la demande croissante de
la part des consommateurs
mais c'est également le besoin pour ces
groupes-là de de mettre en place une
stratégie de transition vers des
produits moins polluants
il faut savoir c'est que la viande le
marché la consommation de viande
aujourd'hui génère
14 5% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre elle est à l'échelle globale donc
de plus en plus de producteurs de
groupes agroalimentaires mais également
des chaînes de supermarchés qui ont des
plans d'ici 2050 passion pour messelet
d'arriver à une lettre à ne plus émettre
de gaz à effet serre ont décidé de se
tourner de diversifier leurs produits
leurs leur portefeuille de produits
ouverts des protéines végétales
également donc il y avait des efforts
qui sont mis en terme de marketing de
recherche et développement à 85 ans le
bénéfice pour l'environnement parce que
souvent c'est l'argumentaire laquelle
c'est bien meilleur dans le caractère de
gaza et fait ça c'est quoi la différence
avec l'élevage animal si on prend
l'équivalent d'un steak haché de boeuf
et si on le compare à un steak haché
végétales on n'a pas même 89 %
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre au
moins pour le steak haché végétal 96 %
d'utilisation des sols en moins 87 %
d'utilisation d'eau en moins donc fait
un impact de même bien moindre par
rapport à gâcher d'origine animale telle
fronde à consommer il faut assurément un
argument à terre pour l'industrie
sofiane belles mélodies merci beaucoup
d'avoir égalé merci pour l'invitation